experience
good afternoon everybody
happy Monday
as many of you are tracking this week
House Republicans will vote for raised
gas prices on American families the
contrast and priorities could not be
more Stark
the the president spent the last two
years as you know doing everything he
could to lower gas prices for American
families and prices are down about 1.60
a gallon since last summer now House
Republicans are using their narrow
majority to force the American people to
pay higher gas prices just as big oil
companies are amassing record profits
what's even more alarming is that this
isn't this is only this is not the only
attempt by House Republicans majority to
raise costs in the middle middle class
families House Republicans are also
pushing a tax increase on middle class
families and inflation worsening tax cut
for the rich and high prescription drug
costs as well these extreme policies
with subject Working Families to immense
Financial pain and balloon our deficit
all just to benefit the wealthiest
taxpayers and big corporations joining
me today as you all see to my right is
Energy Secretary Jennifer Grand home to
talk about how the House Republicans
latest attempt to raise prices for
American families will result in oil
supply shortages and help Putin's War
aims by interfering with our ability to
release oil secretary granholm the floor
is yours thank you for joining us thank
you so much Kareen appreciate it hello
everybody honored to be here again
as Karine said you know President Biden
really has been
particularly focused on reducing costs
for American families especially energy
costs especially both Transportation as
well as at home whether it's you know
increasing the biofuel blends of
gasoline to offering additional funds
through weatherization for lowering
costs for low and moderate income
households but particularly he has acted
to shore up additional oil supply
following the market disruptions that
were the result of Vladimir Putin's
invasion of Ukraine
coordinating with allies and with
Partners through the International
Energy agency he secured globally a
collective release of 240 million
barrels of oil from strategic petroleum
reserves worldwide
as Karine said the average price of a
gallon of gas is now down about a dollar
sixty from last Summer's Peak about a 30
percent decline
and in fact prices are lower today gas
prices are then what they were at the
start of Russia's invasion
analysts who have looked at this have
credited the releases from the Strategic
petroleum reserve for filling the supply
gaps that were resulting from The
Invasion and the lessening of Russian
oil on a global market and have credited
the spr with lowering prices in earlier
in January for example the global head
of energy analysis for the oil price
information service said and I'm quoting
him his name is Tom closer there is no
question that spr sales mitigated the
price impact of crude last year
yet as Karine said House Republicans are
now pursuing this extreme agenda that
risks worse worsening supply shortages
in times of crisis and risks raising
prices gas prices for American families
when you consider H.R 21 which is a bill
that they've introduced it needlessly
aims to weaken the Strategic petroleum
reserves usefulness as a tool to ensure
energy Security in America the spr the
Strategic petroleum Reserve gives us the
means to increase Supply when the market
needed needs it most and it gives us the
tool to increase it quickly quickly
being the operative word speed is key
but HR 21
would impose unnecessary unhelpful
restrictions on when the spr can be used
to help provide Supply it would require
these arbitrary reports regarding energy
production on federal lands before
waiving any new restrictions it would
not offer any tangible benefits to the
American people instead it would
interfere with our ability to be
responsive to release oil during an
international emergency helping Putin's
War aims it would potentially delay
allowing oil to be released for domestic
emergencies following a natural disaster
or a pipeline outage at home leaving
again prices at risk of rising during
the in the wake of a market shock
because of emergencies due to extreme
weather events as I noted in the letter
I sent to the hill last week
be clear there is nothing standing in
the way of domestic oil and gas
production in fact production is on
track for in new record in 2023
from the beginning the president set out
to use spr as a bridge boosting oil
supply while the production ramped up so
so production was down globally because
of Russia's Invasion and the pulling of
Russian barrels off the market
he wanted to increase the Strategic
petroleum Reserve amounts to make a
bridge while calling upon domestic oil
and gas industry to increase production
and that is exactly what has happened
today The spr Remains the largest
strategic petroleum Reserve in the world
and with our plans to refill it at the
lowest uh you know at lower prices
than what we sold at the use of the spr
not only saved Americans money but these
releases will end up delivering a return
for taxpayers and so it's not a tool
that we should be taken off the table
we are willing to work with Republicans
and with Democrats alike to make our
system actually do it more reliable and
more resilient and our country more
energy independent and costs more
affordable
the inflation reduction Act is already
reducing costs and it's made the United
States the most attractive country in
the world to invest in clean energy
production
we believe there's room for
bipartisanship to advance a managed
transition we believe that there is room
for bipartisanship to expand our ability
to create more affordable reliable
energy in America but proposals like H.R
21 which risks raising these gas prices
and making an offered a harder to offer
Americans relief in the future are
simply non-started so I'll be very clear
if Congress were to pass H.R 21
the president would veto it
he will not allow the American people to
suffer because of the backwards agenda
that House Republicans are advancing
with that I'm happy to take your
questions
please
first on uh our exports of liquefied
natural gas and the criticism that some
environmental groups have
surfaced regarding that in climate
change can you address that and number
two Texas is now I think poised or has
already surpassed California in
renewable energy production is there
what do you make of Republican states
like Texas going in on green energy and
are there lessons to be learned from the
way they're doing it as opposed to Blue
States yeah and so first
um with respect to LNG
um we know that our liquefied natural
gas exports have been a significant help
to our allies and it's an important it's
very important to make sure that they
have the means we are fortunate in that
we have an abundance obviously of
natural gas in this country our prices
are low but during times of challenge we
want to help our allies as well we want
to make sure it's the cleanest natural
gas which is one of the reasons why the
inflation excuse me the bipartisan
infrastructure are really invested in
carbon capture strategies and storage
strategies so that's an ongoing issue
and an ongoing conversation we're having
with industry and that includes reducing
methane as well but with respect to
Texas what an opportunity for every
state to be able to produce clean energy
and in fact political story this morning
suggested that there was an abundance of
of announcements coming out of red
States great that is fantastic we want
to be able to see energy clean energy
produced in every pocket of the country
blue states red States really it helps
to save people money so it's really all
about green and green in the sense of
yes it's helpful to the planet but it's
also helpful for jobs and it's also
helpful for us to be energy independent
which is exactly what the president
would like to see homegrown clean energy
independent so that we are strong and
resilient
stations with the Senate have you been
having about H.R 21 well we I think the
Senate knows the position that we have
uh with respect to it and um we'll see
what the Senate does uh with it but
obviously I think there's a lot of
concern that anything that it hampers I
don't care whether it's a Democratic
president or a Republican president why
would you hamper the ability of the
country to be able to respond to
emergencies and hamper the ability of us
to be able to lower costs as a result of
those emergencies so I think the Senate
understands the importance of that and
hopefully will act accordingly
um thanks Madam Secretary you mentioned
the refilling or replenishment of the
spr I know in January you guys I think
kind of rejected offers they didn't move
you know like uh were adequate right to
start that process can relay at least
from the February perspective uh what's
your sense of how successful the process
you guys have laid out will be given
this first uh delay or insufficient
offers and do you have any concerns
about the ability to get exactly what
you need based on the floor and the plan
that was laid out yeah I have no
concerns that we will be able to refill
and replenish the spr and do it at a
savings to taxpayers and our goal was to
start with the first 60 million barrels
of replenishment the offers that we
received did not meet specification or
price and so we're going to stay tuned
for an announcement on how we're going
to go back at that first 60. but we have
a three-part strategy too one is to
accelerate some of the exchanges that
were announced before to get those back
in and second was in the Omnibus us bill
at the end of last year we
canceled the sales of the
congressionally mandated sales for 24
and 25. up through 27 actually so there
was a significant Savings of having to
send out oil but we're going to continue
to work on this I think
in the end because of the way this has
been managed people will be
pleased to see the savings to taxpayers
just real quick could you tease a little
bit of the statement that we're supposed
to be staying tuned for
well
just stay tuned it's gonna happen very
soon
thanks green thanks uh secretary grantol
SO gas prices are now up 33 cents over
the past month
um the president took credit for the
prices coming down the Strategic
petroleum Reserve as you mentioned is no
longer releasing does the president get
credit for the price of gas going up
well it's obviously based upon
International and climate events so for
example winter storm Elliott pulled two
million barrels off the U.S market
because of refineries that went down
that crimp in Supply causes prices to go
up what happens in China are they going
to be opening up soon is there
expectations regarding an increase in
demand that is something that happens on
a global market the whole point of this
is that this strategic petroleum Reserve
is a tool that we have that we can
control we may not be able to control
the weather we may not be able to
control what happens at OPEC Plus or in
China but we can control what we have
access to and that's why this tool is so
incredibly important we'll see what
happens with respect to the price of gas
we know that there are still refineries
that have been pulled down both for
maintenance as well as because of uh of
the of winter storm Elliott but in the
end we think it'll it'll be balancing
out soon
questions
um we sound in the alarm about HR 21 but
let's say uh it did pass in both the
house and the set
um and for whatever reason the president
didn't tell that's a biggest function I
know it is but as you're sounding the
alarm and you've seen some of the the
most um the highest gas prices we've
ever seen in this country if HR 21 were
to pass and be signed into law but what
would it look like at the pump for the
average amount of prices would go up
because we would hush this tool
well it's it's hard to know because we
don't know the circumstances around it
we don't know what would be the reason
for for actually exercising an
additional action at the Strategic
petroleum Reserve but know this
prices would go up because we don't have
this tool and again it's always in
response to an emergency like war or
like you know an extreme weather event
we do know that taking that tool off the
table would harm the American family
the second question when the president
did release the Strategic oil reserves
and and the million day gallons came up
or barrels or whatever yeah we'll get
the numbers but in the midst of that
there were some communities that felt
the relief
other communities did not particularly
those in urban areas there was Christ
gouging Etc could you talk about that
because we're still very uh we're still
this is this could actually happen again
at some point and could you explain why
there was such a difference in
communities with gas prices in one
Community versus yeah I mean there are
definitely differences in terms of
infrastructure across the country and so
some rural areas for example or some who
might be at the very uh end of a of a
line or may not even have a line that
may get it trucked in it takes longer
and it's more expensive if you're not
near a Refinery that's another reason
why the transportation costs are tacked
on at the pump so you're seeing uh for
example when refineries go down in
regions then the prices go up in those
regions much more than they would
Nationwide so a lot of it depends on
local infrastructure
the urban areas because there was still
a big pension urban areas with these gas
prices when the outside communities
particularly majority white communities
were seeing the drop to three dollars
and many of these urban areas were
seeing four and five dollar gas prices
could you speak to that yeah here's what
I would say is that obviously gas
station owners are often into they're
often owned by individuals most of them
are not part of the Branded
oil companies most of them are owned by
individuals and so if an individual is
taking advantage in a region that is
something that for sure now I did when I
was an attorney general uh local
attorney I mean State Attorney General
should go after because gouging is
illegal you cannot take advantage of a
crisis to jack up a prices in that way
so we we encourage
local law enforcement to really get on
it because that should not be happen
absent some other dis you know uh
infrastructure lack that might cause
prices to go up
okay since you oversee the nation's
nuclear Arsenal and it's 11 months now
with the war in Ukraine has anything
changed in your management maintenance
and so forth of uh the nuclear Arsenal
given the potential concerns of War uh
and some of the threats that have come
from Russia well it is clear that we are
singularly focused at the nnsa
of making sure that we have a stockpile
that is safe secure and effective and so
all of the modernization plans that are
happening at the nnsa are um are pointed
in that direction
so it is we're watching this very
carefully obviously but
people should know that we have
incredible relationship with the
Department of Defense and incredible
professionals professionals who are
experts at the nnsa who are focused on
making sure that those three things safe
secure and effective are the adjectives
that we apply to the stockpile
okay thank you thank you
little things and then we'll get going
thank you guys
as you saw last night the president and
the first lady shared their condolences
for those killed and injured in the
deadly mass shooting in Monterey Park
which is in California as you all know
this past weekend the president was
briefed early yesterday morning by his
homeland security adviser Liz Sherwood
Randall Randall and directed her to
ensure full Federal support for local
officials responding to the situation
she continued to provide him with
updates throughout the day and evening
our team continues to be in regular
contact with law enforcement officials
leading the response and the president
has been briefed today on the latest
developments as the president said last
night while there is still much we don't
know about this attack we do know how
deeply it has impacted the aapi
community Monterey Park is home to one
of the largest aapi communities in
America many of whom were celebrating
the Lunar New Year along with loved ones
and friends this past weekend but
instead of celebrating yesterday many
families in Monterey Park were grieving
or praying that their loved one will
recover from their wounds
last night the president lowered the
flags at the White House to half staff
to honor those who lost their lives this
weekend
now turning on to another piece of news
for all of you as you all saw last week
the state department launched the
welcome Corps a new private sponsorship
program that will create opportunities
for Americans to directly sponsor
refugees from around the world arriving
through the U.S Refugee admissions
program the welcome Corps is the boldest
innovation in U.S refuge resettlement in
four decades and will make a meaningful
difference in the lives of refugees and
Americans alike the welcome core program
is designated to strengthen and expand
our country's capacity to resettle
refugees by harnessing the energy of
private sponsors from all over the
United States local communities have
long been at the heart of America's
resettlement program and we have seen
over the past year the overwhelming
response of the American people to
welcome our Afghan allies ukrainians
displaced by War and Venezuelans fleeing
violence and oppression the welcome
Corps Builds on this enthusiasm them by
establishing a durable program for
Americans to privately sponsor refugees
from around the world groups of private
sponsors will help refugees find housing
and employment enroll children in school
and connect with other essential
services so they can thrive in their new
home
the state department is working with a
Consortium of non-profit organization
with expertise in welcoming resettling
and integrating refugees into U.S
communities to make this program a
success this welcome core team will will
guide private sponsors through every
step of sponsorship Journey our goal for
the program's first year is to mobilize
at least 10 000 Americans to step
forward as private sponsors and offer a
welcoming hand to at least five thousand
refugees I'm proud to share we're
already off to a strong start thanks to
the generosity and tremendous support of
Americans across the country nearly 250
diverse organizations representing every
sector National and community-based
service organizations veterans groups
and a wide diversity of faiths have
already joined in expressing their
support for the program more than a
hundred thousand people have visited the
welcome core website since its launch
this past Thursday and over ten thousand
people have signed up for more
information and this week director of
the domestic policy Council Ambassador
Susan Rice and principal Deputy National
Security adviser John feiner will host a
briefing with stakeholders to discuss
the welcome core President Biden made a
commitment to rebuild enhance and expand
the U.S Refugee admission program and
the welcome court is one of the many
ways in which we are doing this we
encourage anyone who is indeed
interested in sponsoring refugees to
visit
welcomecorp.org to learn more about the
program finally we have a preview for
some new travel uh on the president's
schedule for next week next Monday the
president will travel to Baltimore
Maryland and next Tuesday he will travel
to New York City to discuss how his
economic plan including his success
bringing Republicans Independents and
Democrats together to pass the
bipartisan infrastructure law is
strengthening America's economic
competitives creating good paying jobs
and proving that we can still do big
things when we all work together
in Baltimore the president will discuss
how bipartisan infra infrastructure law
funding will replace the 150 year old
Baltimore and Potomac tunnel as you many
of you have probably experienced and
gone through uh during your your outing
in your cars to address the largest
bottleneck for commuters on the
Northeast Corridor between Washington DC
and New Jersey in New York City the
president will discuss how bipartisan
infrastructure law funding for the
Hudson River tunnel project will improve
reliability for the 200 000 passengers
trips per day on Amtrak in New Jersey
Transit
both projects will create good paying
jobs including union jobs lower commute
commuting times and enhanced safety
these two critical important projects
funded by the president's bipartisan
infrastructure law much much like the
the Brent Spence Bridge Project
connecting Ohio and Kentucky that the
president visited just a few weeks ago
alongside Senator Senate minority leader
Mitch McConnell along with thousands of
other projects across the country will
make life better for people in
communities Nationwide during both
visits the president will also discuss
how his economic plan to build an
economy from the bottom up in the middle
out is leading to billions of dollars in
private sector investments in Maryland
New York and across the country with
that see if you want to kick us off the
president of the vice president have any
plans to visit uh Veterinary in Monterey
Park uh
that's a good question don't have
anything to share at this time on any
travel to California specifically
Monterey Park at this time but if we
have if that changes certainly we will
share that with all of you and then over
the weekend there was a reporting that
Brian would be stepping down to shoot
the staff through against my jet science
um can you confirm that and then when
will that change over the effect so look
I know many of you have a lot of
questions on this I know that you might
have some a lot of questions today on
this particular story don't have
anything uh to preview or share or
announce at this time I do want to take
just a personal uh point of personal
privilege as uh when the president was
Senator would say look Ron has been an
incredible boss he has someone that I've
enjoyed working with every day and we
are many of us and I think all of us
here are part of the cleaning acts if
you don't know I suggest you go on
Twitter and find out what the claniacs
are but he has been an incredible leader
an incredible boss as I just stated and
we credit the president as we should for
the impressive legislative successes
historic successes that the president
has had the first two years but in part
it was because of Ron's leadership
incredible leadership that we were able
to get that done so again don't have
anything to share with you all today on
this front but again
um Ron has been an incredible incredible
leader these past two years
[Laughter]
I'll let you follow up on that one feel
free on the uh I'm sure they won't be
shy to follow on the FBI search if the
president's home on Friday the president
won the additional Bachelor documents
were reported a couple of weeks ago said
he was surprised the documents that they
were classified documents down at the
Penn binding Center was he surprised
that there was classified material found
at his home on Friday as well as the
prior to the scottradeous house a few
weeks ago so look again there's going to
be a lot of questions on this I know my
colleagues from the White House
council's office has been pretty
diligent on taking questions these last
couple of days they're going there's
going to be a call in less I think less
than an hour or so from my White House
Council office and look they're going to
answer the questions uh from from uh
from here any specific to the Department
of Justice any specifics to this
particular
legal matter I would refer you to the
Department of Justice I'm going to
continue to be prudent from here I'm
going to continue to be consistent and
and make sure that those questions go to
to my colleagues in the White House
counsel's Office
another question on the documents um you
have said though from this Podium many
many times over the last two weeks that
this President takes the handling of
classified material very seriously and
yet we continue to learn about more
documents being found and discovered at
his home including now some that go back
decades to his time in the Senate so why
should the American people believe that
this President takes classified material
seriously and the handling of it look
the president the American people heard
from the president directly on this when
he was asked by your colleagues at least
twice now about
um
about how he sees this process and he
was very clear what with the response of
what we're currently seeing and he says
I take this very seriously he said I
didn't know that the documents were
there
um and look I think as it relates to the
American people and the president
standing with the American people it is
going to be up to them to decide how
they see this president look this is a
president that came into office nine
million people had lost their jobs the
unemployment rate was 6.3 percent and
hundreds of thousands of small
businesses had closed their doors and in
the past two years we've created nearly
11 million jobs the unemployment rate is
at a record low at 50 50 year record low
in the last two years were the best
years for small businesses applications
on record we talked about that last week
just from here the president has built
the most significant legislative record
since LBJ let's not forget there's a
chips and science act the bipartisan
infrastructure legislation I just walked
through what he's going to see next week
when he's traveling to Baltimore and
also New York City the inflation
reduction act which is going to deal
with lowering costs so the president has
been in office for the last two years
focusing on the American people and you
know we saw that we saw what the
American people had to say during the
midterms as it relates again as it
relates to this as it relates to this
ongoing legal matter I would refer you
to to my colleagues at the White House
Council again they're going to be
speaking with all of you and just and
just you know less than an hour or so
but I want to pass one more time because
you have been the one messaging that he
takes this year so you have also been
saying over and over again that you are
cooperating fully with this
investigation that hasn't changed Mary
but given that why then did it take
several searches and the FBI coming in
to uncover the full extent of the
document that is I understand your
question I've I've said many times the
president has said many times he takes
this very seriously you've heard
directly from him you just said that his
team is cooperating fully and just want
to add you know and you heard from his
team that
the FBI was invited into the president's
home I'm not going to go beyond that
that is that was in the statement that
was released on Saturday again these are
questions uh that should that have been
answered to our you know that have been
answered from here that has been
answered for my colleagues anything else
my colleagues or my colleagues going to
speak to all of you in just a few
minutes a few moments and you can ask
more more Intel in detail you just said
the president said that he did not know
the documents were there I'm not
actually sure he has said that that
clearly are you saying the president
well he said he was surprised he said he
was surprised he said he was surprised
I'm just going to leave it there and I'm
going to refer you to the White House
counsel's office he I'm just repeating
what he said and he said you just said
you said he said the documentary he said
he was surprised that the documents were
there he said that and that he takes
this very seriously that's what I want
to make sure that the American people
understand and I just refer people might
question that given that you keep every
I mean every few days it seems we are
finding that more documents have been
found in his house
what I'm telling you is what the
president has said which is he takes
this very seriously I will refer you to
detailed explanations from statements
that have come from his uh from his
personal lawyer again anything further
on this my colleague is going to be
taking your questions Mary in in the in
the four o'clock hour I would refer you
to them
playing told the president that he's
leaving planning to leave don't have
anything further to share uh and just to
to be very clear Ron Clane is still very
much the chief of staff he is still here
with us I just don't have anything to
share does the president think Jeff
science would be a good chief of staff
Steve Holland do you want to be Chief of
Staff I think I hear I hear a name
someone just called you out as as uh as
protect Chief of Staff material um
popped up on Friday when will speaker
McCarthy visit the president so don't
don't have a meeting to to share at this
uh with all of you at this time uh the
president is looking forward to uh to to
sitting down with speaker McCarthy to
talk about array of issues uh that uh
and this is this is normal right during
a new Congress it is normal for the
president to sit down with the speaker
to talk about how they can work together
you heard the president say this right
after the midterms how he wants to work
in a bipartisan way with members of
Congress to deliver to continue to
deliver on the successes that he has had
this this first two years in good faith
he wants to do this in good faith so
once there's a meeting locked in we
certainly will share that with all of
you go ahead Phil um screen uh on the
dead limit Senator manchin today called
the White House position on their
negotiations for not responsible
yesterday I think he called it the
mistake I understand where your position
is is there any concern that Democrats
not siding that that position could
undercut the effort you guys are trying
to put into place over the next four
months so just let me uh look lowering
the deficit has always been a top
priority when it for this President as
you know he's lowered the deficit in
record fashion at 1.7 trillion dollars
under his presidency and he has said
he's always said he is happy to talk to
anyone who wants to deal with with that
in a responsible way but preventing the
default is a separate matter that is a
separate matter within itself it is a
basic responsibility for congress we've
said this over and over and again and
I'll continue to say this and it's a
responsibility that they that Congress
has to the American people and so it
must be done without conditions even
even as uh they've pushed for a tax
giveaways to the rich Republicans want
to cut Social Security they want to cut
Medicare and other critical programs and
let's not forget these critical programs
already been paid into these are
programs for Veterans for seniors and
taxpayers this is what we're they're
talking about taking away from these
really critical uh critical uh programs
for critical groups here so President
Biden will never will never allow
Republicans to cut benefits that are
that are hard-working Americans have
earned this is what they have earned so
but I'll also know as it relates to
Senator manchin into your question Phil
he agreed on the need to protect Social
Security he agreed on the need to
protect Medicare and called on
Republicans to uh to to take cuts to
those programs off this is quote off the
board right now and so just want to make
that very very clear as well are you
actively asking Democrats Not To Break
ranks on this issue we've been very
clear I don't know
we've been very public about this you
guys have all covered what we have said
from here about how we see this process
moving forward it should be done without
conditions this is some something that
has been done 78 times we were talking
about lifting the debt ceiling in the
past since since 1960 I believe this is
not unusual it's done three times in the
past in the past administration under
Donald Trump so this is nothing unusual
this is something that should be done
without conditions and we should not be
taking hostage Key Programs that that
the American real people really earned
and care about social security Medicare
it should not be put into a hostage
situation and again the president's
going to continue to fight for for those
program and we're going to be very clear
about how we see uh how Congress should
move forward okay thanks Queen the
president said last week that he has no
regrets when it comes to the handling of
classified documents why doesn't he have
regrets given that classified documents
keep turning up I talked about this uh
last week I'm not going to go beyond
what the president said
uh again I would refer you to the White
House Council for anything further on on
this legal matter again I'm just I spoke
to this yesterday I'm just not last week
pardon me last Friday I'm just not going
to go beyond what the presidential
question it's about the history from
last week I understand and I said I'm
not going to go beyond what the
president said and I think it speaks for
speaks for itself I'm not going to go
into uh what he meant or didn't meant he
laid it out he he said it to all of you
and he was uh when he was out out I
believe in California when he answered
one of your colleagues question or what
he addressed this particular matter I'm
just not going to go into what he meant
or didn't mean but going back to what
Mary was asking when the President says
that he takes classified material and
the handling of it very seriously this
weekend top Senate Democrats who have
known him for decades described the
situation as an unacceptable and
completely irresponsible what's the
disconnect here they also said I may add
if I may add that the presidents is
handling this in the appropriate fashion
that the president and his team has been
completely
complying completely with with the
investigation they also said that and so
I will I will leave it up to their
comments up to them uh I'm not going to
go beyond what they have said but they
also said that piece too and I think
it's important to note that they believe
that the president has handled this
properly as well who's paying the
president's private attorney on this
matter I mean it's this private it's his
private attorney so I would leave it I
would I would I would just say it's his
private attorney any questions anything
in particular to this I would ask the
White House Council Office we've asked
that his private attorney at least four
times and they haven't given us an
answer
don't we deserve to know whether he's
paying questions I hear you no I totally
understand Nancy my colleague is going
to be speaking to you moment and
momentarily you can ask that question uh
in that conversation on the record
conversation with all of you
on Friday when we were here you were
asked about uh the president going to
Rehoboth and if that had anything to do
with searches and you declined to answer
that did you know Friday there was a
search going on at the president's home
so I'll say this um and I think I said
this on Friday as well
um they go to Delaware almost every
every weekend we put out guidance last
Monday as you know a Monday night that
they would be spending the weekend in
Rehoboth so it was indeed pre-planned so
just want to put that out there and I'll
just uh you know put I'll just uh
mentioned what was said in the statement
just on Saturday which is the doj
requested that the search not be made
public in advance in line with its
standard procedures and we we did adhere
to that as you could understand that is
something that we are going to take very
seriously uh and it was again a request
from doj for us to to make sure that we
did not make that public in advance
should we anticipate other searches are
possible that part I would definitely uh
refer you to the White House counsel's
Office more broadly given the fact that
classified documents and their handling
have been an issue has the White House
Council put out any guidance to staff
members here who have the opportunity to
interact with classified materials to
just reaffirm how that should be done or
has there been any follow-up on proper
procedures for staffers not the
president not this circumstance no I get
I understand the question again you're
going to have an opportunity to is to
ask that very question to the White
House counsel's office about if they're
going to you know what's their next
steps as it relates to staff that's
something that's better for them to
answer and they'll be speaking to all of
you momentarily okay
I wanted to ask about the president of
Turkey today so that he would not
support Sweden's bid to join NATO
obviously the U.S supports that is there
a concern that that bid could fall
through
so just a couple of things that I want
to make sure I want to Echo the the
comments of the Swedish prime minister
who said burning books that are that are
holy to many is a deeply respectful act
and what is legal is not necessarily
appropriate as we have said before
Finland and Sweden are ready to be NATO
allies both are members of NATO's
partnership for peace and NATO's
enhanced opportunities partnership their
militaries work seamlessly with Alliance
forces Finland and Sweden have already
taken concept steps concrete steps
pardon me to fulfill the commitments
they made under the trilateral
memorandum of agreement with turkey
signed on the margins of the NATO Summit
in Madrid including substantial
strengthening thereby substantially
threatening their bilateral cooperation
with turkey on key security concerns we
continue to expect that NATO will
formally welcome Finland and Sweden as
members this will enhance their security
as well as that of the euro-atlantic
region as their membership process
continues the United States is fully
committed to finland's and Sweden's
accession the strength of that support
can be seen in our Senate's overwhelming
bipartisan vote for their membership
just weeks after their application was
submitted
did you mean disrespectful or respectful
disrespectful act thank you for the
clarity deeply disrespectful act and
just one more question there's a
proposal right now in Congress to tie
the debt limit to GBP would the White
House entertain anything along those
lines so it's basically what I just laid
out like when it comes to dealing with
the deficit it's something that the
president has made his top priority as I
mentioned earlier 1.7 trillion was the
record uh was the the the the record
that the president was able to lower the
deficit under his administration any
ideas he takes any ideas that come to
him in a responsible way he's he's happy
to listen but again this is a separate
matter when you're thinking about
preventing default is a separate matter
and so he believes it should not be done
it should be done pardon me without
conditions and it should be done in a
bipartisan way as it's been done many
times before I mentioned the number 78
that's been done it's 78 times since
1960 three times under the last
president again it should be done
without conditions and that's where we
stand on that
here's a follow-up to the question about
turkey have you all spoken with turkey
since they expressed this public outrage
I don't have a a conversation uh to read
out to you at this time I know that
we've had been asked if if uh if we if
we see them as reliable Partners I was
asked this last week and my answer to
that was yes
I want to ask you a follow-up actually
about this new member's reception that
is coming up do you have any guidance on
how many new members the president tends
to have a follow-up to that actually yes
no it's a good question don't have any
numbers to confirm with to you at this
time again I would have to go back to
the office of ledge Affairs as you know
that process has run through them I
don't have a number to share at this
time on who has confirmed to attend
George Santos invited again I
love how everybody laughed at that um oh
well look as you know every it's a it's
a um it's a event for the new member the
new the new Congress uh so everyone is
invited who is part of the new Congress
I just don't have a contra a
confirmation on who is attending at this
time but I understand the question just
don't have that go ahead all right I
hope you have an answer for this one um
on the debt ceiling crisis
um there's so many different
um agencies and different uh social
programs that are impacted but I want to
ask you this is we're watching this once
again mass shooting are there programs
right now that are in Jeopardy because
the debt ceiling that are targeted on
gun violence mass shootings targeted on
um you know trying to to fix this this
gun crisis in the nation look to your
kind of to your first question uh one of
the things that we have called out is
Republicans threatening to uh to default
uh to force cuts on Social Security to
force cuts on Medicare uh and that is
indeed programs that could be at risk
which is why we continue to call this
out which is why we have said we should
not be using this as a political
football which is why we have said that
in the last since 1960 78 times this has
been done in a bipartisan way and it is
the basic responsibility of Congress to
deal with this issue because there are
programs that are incredibly important
to the American people uh that would be
in Jeopardy if this is allowed there's a
couple of validators that I just want to
read out to you mark Zandy Moody's
Analytics said financial markets and the
economy will crater Larry Summers former
treasury secretary that many of you
speak with a default would be a
catastrophic it would mean higher
borrowing costs forever and lastly Wendy
edelberg from Brookings it's playing a
game with the US economy and people's
lives that I think is irresponsible so
yes there are programs that will
definitely be at risk if this is the if
this is the direction that Republicans
in the house decide to take
another follow-up to this um are there
um efforts afoot in this White House up
and down Pennsylvania Avenue to
safeguard
um if there is this crisis that
continues to win for instance you know
you talked about
um Social Security checks not just
Social Security Medicaid Medicare and
Military checks and other items are you
guys working on any kind of process
to be a safety net so that the military
can get paid so that these checks can
come out in the midst of this crisis as
you're fighting about raising the debt
limit that is constitutional so look
it's a very good question and you're
right veterans senior seniors are
taxpayers uh this is if if uh
Republicans go down this road they will
be the ones who are hurting here we're
going to continue to do what you've been
seeing us do and hearing us from from
myself from this President which is call
this out and say very clearly that we
are we we are uh we Congress should get
this done without conditions and that's
what you're going to continue to hear
from us are there any meetings any
conversations about Plan B plan C Plan D
if this does go into that moment I hear
your question I'm saying there's not
there shouldn't be a plan a plan B plan
C there should not be this should be
done without conditions we should not be
negotiating around this this is again
the last president under the Trump
Administration was done three times in a
bipartisan way
so again we're going to continue to talk
about this we're going to be very clear
and continue to have conversation with
Congress we are talking to Congress I
talked about this last week how the
office of ledge Affairs has been has
been doing Outreach to new members of
Congress in particular to let them know
who is their point of contact what
conversations like opening up for
conversations on things that are
important to them and so we are having
those conversations and will continue uh
to to engage with Congress but again
this should be done without without
conditions 78 times that that Congress
has been able to do this and it is their
basic responsibility their basic
responsibility
uh let's see oh my gosh go ahead thank
you Kareem
um tomorrow Democratic Congressional
leaders will be coming to the White
House what does the president hope to
achieve and will the debt ceiling be one
of the agenda items discussed look a
range of issues as you know this is how
these conversations happen there's a
always a a long agenda of items that
both both sides want to talk about not
going to get ahead of what the
conversation is going to be or what's
going to be actually discussed but the
president has said very clearly he said
very clearly when it uh when it comes to
this new Congress when it comes to
moving forward to deliver for the
American people he's he wants to do this
in a bipartisan way he wants to build on
the successes that we have seen the last
two years that has not changed and
that's working with Democrats that is as
well well we've already we've already
mentioned that there's this is going to
be part of a series of meetings that
will be happening we've talked about the
president looking forward to meeting I
would speak speaker McCarthy so that is
we've already said that uh this is just
one of the first of series of meetings
but look again the President right after
a historic a historic midterm elections
for a Democratic president in 60 years
when you look at uh how the Senate
turned out when you look at that there
wasn't an actual red wave that was being
reported on that he wants to do this and
continue moving forward in a bipartisan
way that's what the American people
wants wants us to do and so that's
always going to be how the president's
going to lead into these conversations
Energy bill secretary granholm outlined
that she doesn't want the US's ability
to draw down these strategic oil
reserves to be hampered in a time of
Crisis but with the administration's
support a minimum threshold of oil to
keep in those reserves for national
security purposes look I'm not going to
get into any policy decisions that the
department of energy is going to be
making you heard directly from the
Energy Secretary from here right here
the podium moments ago just not going to
get ahead of any potential policy making
good Andrew thanks the president's
scheduled to go to Camp David this
weekend just to clarify should we read
any anything into that and
does he have full access to his homes
right now well both Wilmington and
Broadway I would I would refer you to
the White House council's office just
really quick I know you can't say much
about the chief of staff but can you say
whether any women or people
again we don't have an announcement we
have not made an announcement don't have
I understand you're asking me about a
process we haven't made an announcement
uh and uh don't have anything to share
on that front at this time
thank you so much Karine a follow-up on
this story uh on the New York Times this
weekend about
uh Russians agent could be uh directing
Fire by groups to make bombs in Spain is
the White House concerned that Russia
could carry out uh terrorist attacks in
European countries that are supporting
Ukraine as we as you're asking about the
the letter bombs that was been reported
on look I'm not going to get into
intelligence matters or any ongoing
investigation but there are a couple of
General General points that I would like
to make First We Take extraordinarily
seriously the Safety and Security of our
person Personnel abroad including at
Embassy Madrid that means we're doing
everything possible to work with Spanish
Partners to figure out what happened
here and prevent similar threats in the
future second we've offered the Spanish
full cooperation and support in their
ongoing investigations and they know the
important they know the importance to us
of this matter and importance they of
course share obviously the Spanish are
good partners and we're up we're
appreciate for the seriousness which
which they are taking this and
responding to it again not going to go
into any any more details on when it
comes to an intelligence matter
another question about Brazil that taxi
Brazil is linked to also far right
groups uh here in the United States
members of Congress here already asking
the administration to share information
on either some of the planning we're
actually taking place here is that
Administration sharing information with
the Brazilian authorities about that and
he's concerned that the attacks
originating here and what could be due
to counter that from happening from
these kind of attacks being planned here
either in Brazil and other countries I
totally understand the question want to
be very mindful in any intelligence
matters I would uh and I don't want to
comment on diplomatic discussions here
so just gonna leave it leave it there
just learn more about that about that is
that um the White House considering
sanctions imposing sanctions on
individuals or corporations involved in
the January 8 attacks in Brazil again
don't have anything to to share on
sanctions uh totally understand your
question but don't have anything to
share on that on that piece at this time
thank you so much I have some applicant
questions today uh first of all how does
the White House feel about the Russian
foreign minister being in Pretoria being
warmly welcomed and preparing to host
Naval drills with South Africa together
with China so uh so you know we have the
United States has concerns about any
country as we've said before country
exercising with Russia while Russia
wages a brutal war against Ukraine we've
said this before we've been consistent
on this of course every participating
country will make their own decision but
again we have said this before we do
have concerns Express this to Pretoria
or I don't have I don't have any
conversations to read out but we've been
very very consistent as it relates to to
this other Russian involvement on the
continent
um on Friday's announcement that Wagner
has a new designation as a terrorist
group I believe
um what are the consequences for African
governments that work with them uh
Mozambique Mali so on and so forth is
that going to affect the amount of
cooperation between the US and those
countries and is that something maybe
that secretary Yellen might be talking
about with those leaders I will leave
any conversation that secretary Yellen
is having with leaders or has had with
leaders to her to speak to it and to her
office to speak to look we have we've
been very clear about our concerns
especially as a Russia as we have said
many times is is uh is doing this brutal
war against Ukraine uh and uh but I'm
not going to go beyond that
um so more companies are announcing
layoffs we're seeing retail sales drop
off for two months in a row now and
inflation is back to 40-year highs
um is this the stable growth that you've
been talking about if not when does that
stable growth get here well we've been
very very clear and when you think about
uh the inflation it has been look at the
CPI data that came out recently PPI data
that came out recently we have seen that
inflation has been uh going down for the
past six months and that is because of
the work uh that we have that this
president has been doing since he walked
into the administration focusing on uh
on crises right focusing on the on covid
and making sure that there was a
comprehensive way to deal with covet and
making sure people got shots in arms
making sure that the American Rescue
plan was passed that was only voted by
uh by democrats in in in Congress and
those action that he has taken has
helped deal with the economy has helped
actually create 11 million jobs has make
sure that manufacturing jobs uh 750 000
manufacturing jobs have been created
here look we are still seeing a
transition to a stable and steady growth
that is what we're seeing when we look
at the data uh and uh look yes there are
layoffs uh that you're talk you're
asking me about and we've previously
said on the broader economy layoffs
remain near record lows according to job
opening data so these we're looking at
the data and this is what the data is
has been telling us and also let's not
forget unemployment unemployment is down
by is is the lows that we have seen it
in 50 years and so again this is an
economic policy an economic plan that is
working and a lot of it is because the
president has taken bold steps when can
Americans see that stable growth you're
talking about well I think you look at
this again I point it to the CPI data I
taught I pointed to the PPI data where
we have seen inflation coming down let's
not forget the inflation reduction act
where it's going to be implemented in
the next couple of months we're going to
see Americans actually feel uh feel some
relief when it comes to prescription
drugs when it with Medicare being able
uh to negotiate something that they have
not been able to do and so look the
president has taken this very seriously
has an economic plan that's going to
help Americans build the economy from
the bottom up middle out and that's
going to continue to build to be his
Focus look what we have been saying is
we want to work with uh with Republicans
Democrats and independents to continue
on the successes that we have seen in
the last two years continue on the
historic historic legislation
implementing those legislation and
that's what you're going to see from
this President go ahead Peter thank you
Kareem when you found out that the FBI
had located even more classified
materials in Wilmington which
four-letter word did you use
oh
my goodness Peter um
[Laughter]
uh President Biden is still intending to
run for re-election in 2024 right uh
I'll just repeat what the president said
after the midterm election which is he
intends to run I'm going to be very
careful from here as you know uh because
we are covered by the Hatch Act and I'm
not going to speak further to his
process is there a precedent for people
running for president after FBI agents
search their stock drawer say that one
more time say that beginning part is
there a precedent for people running for
president
it sounds like you already know that
that the answer to that question look
here's what I here's the answer to that
question here's here's the eye search of
the president's residence is a big big
deal here's what the president's going
to focus on he's going to focus on
continuing to deliver for the American
people that's his Focus that's what he
focuses on every day that's what he's
been focusing on the last two years and
nothing is going to change that you
think about the bipartisan
infrastructure legislation you think
about the inflation reduction act you
think about the chips and science act by
part those the bipartisan one the last
two that I mentioned done in a
bipartisan way that's what the president
wants to do he wants to continue to
deliver on his economic plan that is
going to build the economy from the
bottom up middle out that is what
matters to the president the house
oversight committee chairman says this
document situation has all the makings
of a potential cover-up is President
Biden involved in a cover-up
we've been very clear here from
this Administration the president has
been very clear
that he takes this very seriously when
it comes to
that when it comes to classified
information when it comes to classified
documents and that his team has been has
been fully Cooperative with this legal
matter anything else Peter and this is
and I'm going to be very serious you
asked me kind of a question that
everybody laughed at which was
interesting question to ask but any
other any other underlying questions
that you may have I would refer you to
my colleagues the White House counsel
I'm going to continue to be prudent I'm
going to be continue to be consistent
and refer you to any questions you have
there
okay
um we are approaching the statutory
deadline for the president to submit his
budget to Congress the deadline is the
first Monday of February which is two
weeks from today so when does he plan to
submit that budget and we do it before
that deadline okay uh Joey it's a good
question when we have have more to share
about that budget process certainly we
will have that to share with you the
OMB is that is something that the OMB is
working an issue that the OMB director
is working very hard on and very closely
on once we have more to share we
certainly will lay that for you lay that
out for you okay Karen has the president
invited the justice department to search
his home
refer you to the White House council's
Office who will be speaking with all of
you pretty soon okay
on January 12th in response to my
question you told me the search is
complete he the president is confident
in this process but since then the
searches have continued more documents
have found uh is the president still
confident in this process and how his
lawyers have carried out the search for
material in his residences he's
confident in this process
um and my colleague has talked about
this this is an ongoing process and you
know we've continued to provide the
information that we've had at the time
anything else anything specific
underlying issues on this or questions
that you may have I would refer you to
the White House counsel's office and a
non-process question then we had a poll
with ipsos ABC news ipsos that was taken
before the most recent items were
discovered that found that 64 of
Americans believe the president acted
inappropriately in the way he handled
classified files how worried is the
White House that this issue is hurting
the president's trustworth
in the eyes of Americans look our focus
is going to continue basically what I've
said to your colleagues on delivering
for the American people that's going to
be our Focus that's what the president's
going to do every day in and out which
is what can we do to make the lives of
Americans a little bit better and that's
what he has done and I've laid out the
historic pieces of legislation that the
president was able to do some of them in
a bipartisan way and many of the pieces
of legislation that have passed by his
Economic Policy plan has changed our
lives and will change the lives of
millions of Americans across the country
that's going to be our Focus not going
to go into you know a rabbit hole or go
into details or thoughts about polls
that's not what I'm going to do from
here what we're going to do is talk to
all of you every day about what our
message is to the American people and
continue to have that healthy back and
forth and talk about our policies talk
about what the president is doing again
every day with the vice present with his
team to make sure that we deal with
issues that truly truly matter to the
American people just yesterday you saw
you heard from the Vice President in
Tallahassee who talked about an issue
that mattered to the American people we
saw that right coming out of the
midterms which is making sure that
women's rights were being protected when
you think about Rogue yesterday it would
have been 50 years of row which was a
constitutional right for Americans and
so that's what Americans want to
continue to see us do fight for their
rights continue to deliver in a way that
they can feel it right when it comes to
gas prices bringing those prices down
when it comes to a health care costs
bringing those costs down and that's
really going to be our Focus
go ahead Phil thank you when you and the
White House and the President also say
that the president takes these
classified documents very seriously
without commenting on the ongoing legal
issue what would you point us to that
would demonstrate that seriousness
I'm going to really refer you to the
White House council's office I I am I'm
going I yeah I am so the president
continues to say it takes us seriously
and you can't demonstrate how he takes
it seriously let me just finish let me
finish my answer I'm gonna I'm gonna
refer you to the White House council's
office and I'm going to refer you to the
statements that you've received from his
personal lawyer I'm going to refer you
to the 45 minutes of conversation of
back and forth that my colleague has had
with all of you last week he's about to
do another one where you can ask
questions about this particular legal
matter again that's where this belongs
that's where I'm going to refer you to
but again you've seen the statements
you've heard from the president a couple
of times you've heard from his personal
lawyer you've heard from the White House
counsel's office and that's where I'm
going to leave it the house has passed a
bipartisan legislation that would ban
the export of oil from the Strategic
petroleum Reserve to Chinese companies
given that oil has flowed China from
that Reserve during both this
Administration and the previous one is
that the type of Reform that the
president would potentially support so
look I think this is a little bit of
what the secretary was talking about
just moments ago this bill addresses a
non-issue we're very clear on that we
focus we're focused on advancing
legislation that would lower costs for
American families not raise them so I'm
just going to leave it there
uh just two quick ones one does the
prayer I know the presidents have
answered a few questions here and there
but is there any plans for the president
to come out and sort of address this
investigation in a more fulsome way give
more of a detailed timeline I know
you're referring us to the council's
office but I'm wondering if we will hear
more fully from the president himself on
this matter look as you just stated in
your question to me the president has
addressed this uh spoken about this a
couple of times and I don't have
anything to announce right now but he's
going to continue again to take
questions from all of you as he has done
these past several months these two
years and he's going to take those
questions as he understands on behalf of
the American people as you guys ask
questions and and do your reporting just
don't have anything to announce
specifically on on that question okay
thanks everybody see you tomorrow